where do I put my highlighter when I do
my makeup baby okay moving on we are
gonna play the Kylie quiz and see how
well do you know me
first question first question what color
is my toothbrush pink okay it's someone
keeping track but he makes somebody
doesn't make it is think it is pink
correct what are my dog's name Norman
okay lady lady lady
well actually what it inlay baby there's
four I know I know
because there's a girl prettier like
what's her name
Bambi okay and then Rosie Harley yeah
yeah got it
I didn't get that right that was a no
wait it was like who at it - okay wait
who's who's the alpha dog out of all his
dogs all right man I got that right boom
what sport what are like two sports I
played growing up track and sport
basketball
oh I did play soccer but it wasn't it
wasn't good it wasn't this morning back
and I don't know I mean technically I
did play soccer
so I write those words I Chi really I
did cheerleading anti sport boys
football team two boys football team I
played off the boys football team black
only flags
that's not our sport flag football is it
on ESPN No
alright is no sport soccer I got that
right right okay then what's the biggest
scar on my body the biggest scar on your
leg which leg how long does it usually
take to do my makeup hour two hours two
hours it might feel like two hours
no like through two hours their makeup
that's a fact is either you tell her
wait hours before or she's not going
black how many cavities have a had done
a question what did I eat the most when
I was pregnant in and out back what's my
middle name
how many tattoos do ABS I don't count
your tattoos but okay you got one right
here
yeah um ankle like bad but type other
ankle I don't think you're gonna get
this last one and then I don't know
oh no
I know they from the younger days she
give me a hint it's a heart
you don't know where this is hard cuz I
are the back of my arm
oh whatever this isn't we're not even
doing this right cuz you were supposed
to guess how many and I'm telling no
that's impossible
how many times do i I don't know exactly
okay what are my parents birth names
birth names my parents birth names first
names reason no you know this remember
the other day we were talking about this
it was a good night so it's funny that
those are my parents first names no one
knows that Kristen and William oh yeah
yeah oh yeah Williams I'll think of any
yeah okay whatever
thought you were gonna get that one um
what color are my onyx green sometimes
hello where that's like because it's a
big deal
will color my eyes wow you know that
what nickname do we call stormy spawn
there we go you know so many nicknames
what's like one of the nicknames I call
you anything
just calling baby or daddy sometimes
what's my astrological sign we hear
Taurus
I don't even know [ __ ] about that so
strong as an Aquarius
what's my favorite flavor ice cream and
the brand haagen-dazs is your favorite
brand favorite ice cream is deaf and
dumb vanilla what
it's definitely vanilla oh I got that
right
what's my order at Madh pizza everybody
pizza with a little bit of oregano okay
what's your favorite so that I cook for
you late night snack not food but like
Peter Byrne Jovi that's your favorite
that's my favorite I am a master peanut
butter jelly maker no he's not just
saying that like I really am the best
yeah just like that it's the way that um
the crust is cut off it's like no no
crust it's perfect birthday and the
perfect amount of peanut butter and
jelly like I take it really seriously
shoes yeah but it's something I request
personally so much before night night
he loves peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches
this is like the diagonal cut yeah it is
the diagonal nobody like you want to
know what there's all started actually
it was like our plane ride back from I
don't remember but we were coming home
from somewhere and the flight attendant
on the
he's like really bomb sing about our
jelly sandwiches and then after that I
think we eat a PB&J like every night
smooth grape jelly and I think that was
a problem with the plight of children
attendance Pedro jelly is a crunch like
crunchy no it was wheat bread yes we
bran has to be white bread pita bread
jelly but it's trying to white bread
yeah man yeah I'll do a youtube video on
it yeah wanna do first of all we're not
giving out my peanut butter jelly recipe
to mother [ __ ] I love you so much
[ __ ] that
where did we first meet we still don't
know this answer it's a lot of there's a
lot of link ups Oh where do we first
meet and what did I think of you you
thought I didn't like you well we kind
of first always knew each other like we
were hanging around each other I mean we
just had mutual friends that's what it
was but we never really had a
conversation yes I thought that he
didn't like but now I know it's crazy
oh wait I shadow I don't know is it
peachy I don't know dude what the [ __ ] I
don't know she let me go that's really
good that's really good
well I posted all the time on my
Instagram and I hope that you look at my
Instagram may not do you know it's hard
to keep up with the names I'm so like
what's our favorite show to watch
together we watch all different types of
shows well the thing about it we've
never finished the show together because
and watch the mythology finish watching
do you go and you watch them without me
no we shall I start watching them and
didn't like we try to watch him and then
she doesn't let me watching or one of us
falls asleep what hospital was I born in
what see which one of my sister's do I
hang out with the most
what is my favorite Travis Scott song I
play the most that's the older one hell
of a night
[Laughter]
actually um long long long long long
long long long time it's like my first
mixtape I just remember a job that
mixtape and I got on Instagram and she
made this video her I was in [ __ ]
Thailand oh yeah and I made a video like
on the beach to sell overnight actually
do you like that video on Instagram who
came up with the name stormy I want you
to just like zoom in on my shape Jacques
Herman Webster in a second and let's not
get it twisted thank you
and the score you did pretty good
[Music]